let's talk about obviously ATL took a
big loss hip-hop took a big loss uh one
of your peers uh take off passed away RP
takeoff man yeah that that [ __ ] me up
bro you guys have a very similar uh
trajectory in terms of just timelines of
your guys's career yeah that's what I
said that's what I was saying earlier
like them that took off at the same time
like I remember
um
takeoff I remember the Migos us all
being over the Gucci spot bro before
anybody gotta do a thug over there
Scooter over the Migos on the couch you
know what I'm saying everybody there so
just to see them grind to get to where
they uh what they are you know I mean it
was just like and to see where we
started from and watch every move like
I I saw them transition like they saw me
transition so it's like they're my real
brothers man so that it was a huge hell
and me just knowing like
[ __ ] that could have been me
so it just it fold your brain man [ __ ]
with your brain bro dude I love Houston
so much like that's one of the Cities I
said I would move to if I would ever
leave Atlanta yeah no state taxes great
City yeah hey baby so that that that
[ __ ] me up yeah I can imagine man yeah
because I just think like you guys very
were like synonymous with each other in
terms of like who was kind of running
the club scene yeah like 15 it was like
it was y'all
and it was them yeah like I remember
um
some type of way
um Versace took off for like same time
same time 2013. I remember it like it
was yesterday I remember I was doing a
birthday bash and stuff together so it's
like man we shot so many memories
together man you feel me like
and you don't even know you create
memories when you're living in a moments
like you don't even know they're gonna
be members if you feel me so I try to
cherish most of my relationships with
sit down bro because you know I never
know when I'm be gone what was uh I mean
I don't know how close you would take
off for but that's the story you you
have maybe you know whether it was
Birthday Bash or just a timer you guys
maybe had a convo or or had a memory
together that you know you always hold
dear
um like I said man it just mostly just
take man just him standing in the cut
man I always [ __ ] get high solo key
yeah SOLO low-key last time I saw him
was at qcp uh P had a birthday party
like a man Gala in the Jordan in Atlanta
at the spot yeah yeah so being quavo
flicked up and stuff and he was right
there like the hair going in a cut you
say much but he had a blunt and Dark
Shades on you know what I'm saying so
messages follow me different bro and
just hit me different man then I know
his character he made me like you know
me quiet to himself
and the way it happened
yeah it's sad man it's a tragedy
yeah it's a tragedy because it's not
like you said like
it's not like he's the kind of guy who
yeah like he was was putting that energy
out there that's what I'm saying like he
wasn't even putting it in the atmosphere
you know what I'm saying so it's
different for somebody like that like
sometimes people will pass and you'll be
like well look like obviously they're
wrapped up in a certain life or they're
putting they were kind of putting that
[ __ ] out there that's what you want you
know you live I just told you that by
the sword but that wasn't the case in
that situation man so like that's one
thing Atlanta been just devastated man